hello everyone and thank you all for
joining
yon almighty and myself for the the
early morning unannounced stream it was
a quite the enjoyable experience as
always over 350 people in the tournament
playing that's not not bad for an
unannounced stream and over 700 people
in the stream at one point so very nice
this game here it's from the 12th round
of the world rapid championship and it's
the reason why you should why you should
really study how to play the end game
the end game is so important and you'll
see what I mean after you see this game
Carson is facing Russian Grandmaster
Vladimir Pharaoh save federer self has
the white pieces and he's quite a deadly
player this is round 12 he's been in the
lead he's been in first place for the
entire tournament
he faces Magnus Carlsen here and it's
it's I mean you'll see what it really
takes to win a tournament Pharaoh save
has the white pieces and he plays efore
we have E 5 Knight to f3 96 and Bishop
to b5 the Royal opus already you know
that it's gonna be a highly theoretical
game a6 the Morphy defense Bishop a4
Knight to f6 now feather save castles
Bishop to e7 and rook to e1 still the
main line of the Morphy defense b5
Bishop to b3 and d6 now by Carlsen c3
cross and castles we have d4 Bishop to
g4 Bishop to e3 eke after son d4c
capture son b4 end and Knight to a5 now
going for the light square bishop and
here the usual
idea is for Bishop to retreat the c2 and
white contain is developing always well
but here Pharaoh server decides to go
for night to d2 Knight B to d2
developing a piece also protecting the
bishop on b3 Carlsen captures the wish
of Knight captures and we had a captures
already Pharaoh said this is move 13
creates some sort of an imbalance in the
position he doubled his own pawns but he
did get an open a file for the rook in
in exchange and it would it would really
be great for Carlson if he could push
maybe a five to prepare a four in the
future and failsafe of course we'll want
to try and block a do this by playing b4
so Carson goes for c5 we have Queen to
c2 and Knight to d7 by Carlsen a five by
Pharaoh safe C captor son before we have
Bishop captor son d4 and here Carlson
decides to go for a series of exchanges
D captures on e5 Knight captures and
Knight captures Bishop captures and it's
a you know it's a pretty pretty decent
position federal safe still has doubled
be pawns Carson has the possibility of
maybe pushing a five and a four in the
future and it seems like already in the
position there's this rook to c8 move
that allows Carlsen to attack the Queen
after the Queen moves that he can win
the night and e2 unfortunately this
isn't possible
I mean unfortunately for Carlsen Queen
to e4 now if you grab the night on be to
fit of safe grabs the bishop on g4 and
after f5 you have a queen - b7 now again
if you grab the knight Pharaoh save
grabs the bishop on e7 so Carlsen he
Coco is the position for for awhile and
the place rook to e8 decides that this
variation doesn't have any merit Bishop
to c3
Bishop to f8 by Carson Carson offers the
exchange of rooks as well we have h3
Bishop to h5 and Queen to f5 now
attacking the bishop and also improving
the position of the Queen Bishop to g6
kicking the Queen away and Queen to f4
guarding the knight on D - I mean adding
more protection to the night and here
Carson plays rook captures anyone he
exchanges a pair of rooks rook captures
and we have Queen to d7 here
the official commentator meters
Timoshenko suggested that a5 may be
followed by a 4 would it definitely be a
better idea but the constant decides
against this he plays Queen to d7 and
nice to f3 by fellow save we have f6 f6
is a Miss a great move it kind of really
nullifies the influence of this Bishop
on c3
sorry also prevents the knight from
infiltrating the position with 95 or
Knight g5 also makes a nice a nice
square for the bishop on f7 if needed so
definitely a useful move and we have
Bishop to b4 now we have rooked rook to
e8 Carlsen offers the exchange of a
second rook which federal Civ accepts
rook captures Bishop captures and we
have Bishop captures and King captures
and here we have b4 so fellas I have
managed to exchange all the pieces and
put before locking these pawns on light
squares and making his own pawns stay
and dark squares Coulson has a light
square bishop so of course Pharaoh say
wants his pawn on dark squares and here
it's a it's a dead drawn position if you
consider the material and probably if
you consider the position and most
likely every other player out there
would consider offering a draw here but
as you all know magnus carlsen is is an
endgame beast and he wants to play this
so Queen to e7 by Carlsen we have nice
to d4 King to f7 and Queen to d2 the
queen is now guarding the night the
night is nicely placed here controlling
some important squares Queen is also
protecting the B to pawn the v4 pawn so
no surprises can happen here really
cross and plays Queen to d6 we have
Queen to c3 and Bishop to d7 slowly but
surely Carlsen tries to improve the
position of his pieces Queen to b3 now
and here Bishop to e6 Carlsen offers a
trade of well of Bishops and in essence
the Queen's and this wouldn't really go
in Fellowship's favor if Queen captures
on e6 Queen captures Knight characters
and King captures it's actually a
winning and game for black the black
king is so much more active than the
White King
simply king d5 2.c4 capturing before and
this is completely winning for black so
after Bishop e6 Queen to c3 we have
Bishop to d7 Carlson wants to exchange
Queens but he doesn't want to exchange
his Bishop for a knight
Queen to b3 check and came to e7 Queen
back to c3 Queen to e5 now Queen to d2
and the G
5.now carlson starts expanding on the
kingside knight Knight to e2 we have
Bishop to c6 Knight the d4 attacking the
bishop bishop to d5 and already you can
see some 10 moves ago all of Carlson
species were on the back ranks now he
has a queen and E 5 Bishop on d5 and the
Queen the king is a bit more active as
well
Queen to c3 and King back to f7 Queen to
d3 we have King to f8 and this was a
here it's very hard to decide Federal
service threatening to capture the H the
H 7 pawn and here are a lot of moves
were possible probably Queen to e4
but if Queen's were exchanged in this
position it it might not be such a great
position for Carlsen so instead Carlsen
place came to a fate of course you can't
capture the the h7 pony or Knight will
be hanging on d4 and the King is
actually pretty safe on f8 Queen to c3
now again threatening to infiltrate and
we have h5 & Quinta ch-check is possible
but it doesn't really achieve anything
the king will the king will find safety
simply can give 7 king g6 the king will
be perfectly safe there f3 by Pharaoh
save and we have h4 now King to f2 King
to f7 and now Queen - III now Pharaoh
save offers a trade of Queens and costs
and accepts Queen capture screen
captures and we have king to e7 and if
you look at this position again it seems
like it's the position is dead drawn
it's very hard for any player to make
progress here we have 9th to c2 by
Pharaoh save Bishop to b3 and knight
back to d4 Bishop back to d5 by Carlson
and again night the c2 it seems Pharaoh
save doesn't really see a way of making
progress here he's repeating moves and
offering a draw across and place came to
e6 improving the position of his King
and we have night the e1 Bishop the c-4
by Carlsen f4 now Pharaoh said would
like to exchange as many points as
possible this will make the draw happen
but happen a bit faster well not a bit
faster but there's a greater chance for
a draw if you exchange as many pawns as
you can
King to have five by Carlsen we have F
captors on g5 and F captors and g5 and
Knight to f3 now controlling that g5
pawn bishop to d5 by Carson and night to
d4 check King to f6
we had a knight back to f3 and Bishop to
b7 here Carlsen really has to figure out
a way how to do this he was he was up on
up on the clock and the first set was
down to two one minute on the clock but
you know it's an intense game and there
is a lot hanging in this game Pharaoh
said was leading the entire tournament
and the cost and after losing that game
- - boo in the beginning of the
tournament and he also lost the game -
Anand really took him a lot of wins the
to get back back on track so basically
the winner of this game will take sole
lead in the tournament king - f2 by
Pharaoh save King - f5 now and here
Pharaoh 7 men ages to push g3 exchange
one more pawn cross and captures H
captures King captures and Bishop to c8
knight back to d2 Russia back to b7
Knight to f3 and Bishop to d5 Knight the
D - we have Bishop to f7 knife to f3 and
now Bishop to d8 knight back to d2
Bishop to f7 Knight to f3 and now Bishop
to h5 and this Bishop to h5 is actually
the crucial move that allows Carlsen to
continue playing this game night to d4
check and here comes Knight to e5 Knight
to f3 check forking the king and the g5
pawn and here call someplace tink to d5
and this King to d5 move allows Pharaoh
safe to capture the g5 pawn and this is
the idea of the bishop of being on h5
Pharaoh safe plays Knight captures on g5
and cost and place came to see for the
idea was all along for Carlsen scheme to
come to the Queen side to grab these
pawns but you had to really time it with
the bishop and h5 because now fit of
safe can't start pushing his own age
h-bond towards towards h8
Knight to e4 by Pharaoh save King
some before now we have King to f4 a
five by Carlson night to d2 and as you
can see now this night and pawn are
actually creating a nice wall against
Carson skink so Carlsen can't approach
the spawn and be too
but a4 is coming we have King to e4 kink
the c5 King to e3 now before Knight to
e4 check King to d5 now knife to d2 and
the bishop to g6 and not oh I mean the
King to get anywhere near those pawns
King to eat - and now comes a three b
captures be captures and king to d1 and
after a two and night b3 it seems like
Pharaoh say we'll be able to create some
sort of a castle here but as you all
know cousins famous quotes states that
he doesn't believe in castles story in
fortresses kink the c4 we have 92 a1 now
blocking so the King can't enter this
position and here comes King to c3 King
to see one now of course Carlsen can't
approach this but here comes Bishop to
a5 and here afghani meters mashenka said
that he knows this end game and that he
knows that it's winning for black but he
knows the same game without without
white having an extra pawn but he said
as cousin is playing so fast here that
surely Carlson knows this am game by
heart
even with the extra pawn White has on
the H file so here Carlson shows us
house how to win this endgame h4 he
plays Bishop to g6 now why doesn't have
any moves the knight can't move if you
play if you play Knight C to simply
Bishop will capture it you have to move
the pawn it's kind of a I mean it is a
tubes one so h5
Bishop captures night the c2 and now
Bishop to EA the idea is you have to put
your Bishop on a4 for this to be a
winning position night back to a-1 and
now Bishop to a4 we have night to see -
and now of course you don't capture the
night if you play Bishop capture Sun
City on c2 it's a stalemate but after
this night to see to cross someplace
King to b3 and
in this position wad me the fellow said
resigned the game as a white doesn't
have any move whatsoever because now if
you play Knight to a one check simply
King to a three and there is no there is
no move here if you move the King for
example King D to Dan King your own king
is coming to be two and if you play
Knight to see to check now cousin can
capture at King captures and you bring
out the Queen and on the other hand
after King to be three if you play
something like Knights the D for check
again King to a three and there is no
way to approach the King and pawn are
blocking the White King from approaching
and the knight has no more moves so
pretty pretty simple 995 trick doesn't
work Bishop simply captures that if you
go back again Bishop will capture it
it's the same position so after this
tough tough endgame after King b3 and
this is move 84 Vladimir's federal save
resign the game and Carlson takes sole
lead in the tournament after round 12
three more rounds to go so it's gonna be
it's gonna be very intense so yeah
that's the game and you know the the
moral of the story studied the endgame
you know you might find yourself you
know completely drawn in game against a
world-class Grandmaster and you know you
can draw the game or you can simply win
the game like the Carson does it's
basically your choice so yeah I would
like to thank dear Cooney team and paste
in Matthew Neely and David Guzman Ruiz
for a contribution to my channel thanks
a lot - really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
they will both be from the world rabbit
championship here and feel free to
suggest any games that are to your
liking I will make sure to read all the
comments thank you all and I will see
you soon